and i want to welcome you to the
workshop on quantifying uncertainty
stochastic adversarial and beyond
um first of all i want to thank the
organizers for for putting together a
great program for you this week though
doris lucaris
laura duvall
and kevin jameson
[Music]
just a few logistics we provide food
before the talks and during the breaks
for lunch you're on your own but
fortunately berkeley has a wide variety
of eateries close by
um we ask that you do leave food outside
the auditorium to keep it clean
and if you want to leave stuff here
during the lunch breaks there are
lockers on the far side on this first
floor that you can access via a pin code
our videographer omid far will be
helping to set up talks this is a hybrid
workshop today
this week
and i want to give a special thanks to
ashley hansen who handled all the local
arrangements and putting this together
so thank you ashley
now i will hand things over to the
capable hands of fedoras who will guide
you to the rest
thank you thanks so much for coming and
uh yeah so we organized that with a lot
of valkyries here and kevin jameson who
is there
uh so
in this workshop we are going to focus
on the role of uncertainty and
information structures in sequential
decision making
and i just have one slide just to give
an idea of the themes that you're going
to see in the workshop and it's useful
during the talks to actually come back
to the themes to to think essentially
how they are getting together
so and all these things the themes that
i will mention its talk does not fit
into one theme only but they're going to
be interleaved but it's useful to keep
that in mind
so the first thing that we try to
capture was adaptive experimental design
so in many situations when you do
sequential decision making you have the
option to adaptively select the data
that you're going to select or also
possibly use offline data in order to
enhance the performance of your
algorithms so
it's something that we try to we're
going to see more in this talk is how
can you do for example sequential
hypothesis testing and how can you use
adaptivity in sequential decision making
the second thing has to do with hybrid
models between stochastic and versatile
so in the bootcamp i gave a talk about
how one can try to bridge these two
extremes we are going to see more such
settings where you have a nice structure
that you would like to use in your data
but also you would like to be robust to
the structure not holding without
reverting to completely worst case
approaches
the third thing that would be useful is
information feedback models so the
classical models are full information
where you assume that you learn
everything about
all
about everything that is happening and
there's the bandit feedback model where
you only see what happened for the
particular action in many of the talks
we're going to see more complex and
richer feedback models and it's useful
to keep in mind essentially how these
come together and what differences the
particular feedback model makes
and finally we are going to discuss
incentives and we are going to take an
economics approach approach towards
sequential decision making
if we're going to think about situations
where the data are coming from strategic
agents and we're going to think about
how one can try to reason about them and
understand the
and
make decisions in situations where uh
data comes from strategic components
on a logistical level we're going to
have 27 fantastic talks so we are going
to have nine sessions so
it's morning we're going to have three
talks and this afternoon we're going to
have uh
three talks this is for real days not
named wednesday on wednesday we're going
to have more activities so you should
all join for that
we're going to have a panel we're going
where we're going to discuss about how
different disciplines approach
sequential decision making and what are
the boundaries that
the models that its community uses
introduces and what are what how can we
create connections between the
communities
and we're going to have two student
poster sessions students and postdocs we
have 17 posters for each poster session
so it will be very exciting and you're
going to see a bunch of junior
researchers present their work so you
should not come to that
and without further ado i will
give
the microphone to laura to introduce the
procession
one way to think about
this first session we need to keep in
mind that usually mobile experimentation
will be either
mini-dimensional states or independence
supposedly such as information and the
models
they are expanding and breaking through
these assumptions and um
the first two talks won't be necessarily
all strategic components but then we'll
still sort of bring these two components
together and layer incentives
fantastic
okay thank you
i just have to let this down
um
thank
you okay um so first just thanks to the
organizers for putting together this
fantastic workshop and for having me as
a part of it
so this is joint work with shao shenmue
and bacillus or kenkis and the paper is
about dynamically aggregating
information
so specifically we look at the question
of how an agent should optimally acquire
information over time when that agent
has limited resources or attention with
which to acquire that information and
moreover has to decide how to spread
those resources across multiple
different kinds of information
so to give you some concrete examples so
that's a little bit dates the paper to
when we were writing it up but suppose a
mayor wants to know the coveted
incidence rate in his city
uh how you might do that is by testing
people at different testing centers each
located in a different neighborhood okay
you have a fixed total number of tests
to allocate across these different
testing centers
perhaps you get a new batch each day how
do you want to do that allocation
okay for a different example
suppose you're a news reader that wants
to learn something like the unknown cost
of a proposed policy
okay you can learn about this by reading
different news sources potentially these
new sources are biased in different
directions
so how do you want to allocate your
spares time towards reading these
different news sources
okay so what i'm going to show you is
first a model of this dynamic
information acquisition problem
okay it turns out that in this model the
optimal information acquisition strategy
can actually be exactly characterized
and moreover that solution takes a
rather simple form
okay so i'm going to spend most of the
talk just telling you about the nature
of that solution and why it ends up
looking like that
right because the solution is so
tractable it's easy to use in
applications and in the paper we
actually ourselves exploit that for
three different economic applications
okay so it's a short talk today so i
won't have time to go into any detail
about those but i'll try to briefly give
you a sense of what we did
time permitting
okay so let's go straight into the model
there's going to be k unknown attributes
model as this jointly normal state
vector theta 1 through theta k
you can think about this
normal distribution as the agent's prior
belief
in the cobit example we might think
about each attribute as being the coded
incidence rate within a specific
neighborhood
now importantly in this model we're
going to allow for the attributes to be
correlated right so that's going to be
important for a number of applications
in the covet case we might think that
neighborhoods which are located closer
to each other or which are
demographically more similar
might have correlated incidence rates
now the decision maker is going to learn
about these attributes
by observing a source of information
about that attribute which we're going
to model as a diffusion process and i'll
tell you more about that in a moment
okay now
we're going to assume that
although we have k different unknown
attributes these attributes are
aggregated into a single unit
dimensional payoff relevant state which
is going to enter into the individual's
utility function
right so this payoff relevant state
omega is an arbitrary linear combination
of these unknown states okay this is
this is equivalent up to a constant to
just assuming that omega together with
the attributes is jointly normal
we're going to assume that the weights
alpha k
are known to the decision maker in the
coveted case you could think about that
as being the fraction of the city's
population that is located in the given
neighborhood
right so attention allocation yeah
omega if the thetas are correlated
aren't we double counting stuff by just
having this product
so i'm not
yeah absolutely um but it's okay but so
these are two different kinds of
uh ways in which it might enter the
utility function so the alphas are going
to be persistent right so whatever
beliefs that might hold about theta
these alphas are the same in contrast
the perceived coordination of the
different attributes is going to evolve
over time as they update my release to
information
okay so attention allocation is going to
be the focus of this paper and we're
modeling that as follows so time is
going to be continuous
and we suppose that at every moment of
time the agent has a unit budget of
attention to allocate across learning
about the different attributes
okay so formally you're going to choose
an attention vector with beta1 through
beta k
which sums to one okay that's your
attention cap
where these attention choices are going
to influence the evolution of the
diffusion processes
right so fixing for example theta i
right there's an associated diffusion
process
the increment of that process at time t
is given by this expression here
okay the drift is theta i that's what
you want to learn
times beta i t which is the amount of
attention you're allocating towards
learning about theta i at time t
this part is an independent standard
brownian motion this part is a
normalization i think the specific
parametrization will be more clear in a
moment okay and what's important to see
is that if you allocate more attention
towards learning about an attribute
that's going to increase the signal to
noise ratio of the increment so you're
going to be learning more about that
attribute
so there's a natural discrete time
analog to this model
let's take time to be discrete uh and
suppose that in each period you have a
budget of precision
to allocate across k different normal
signals
so for each attribute we're going to
observe the signal which is theta i
plus a gaussian noise term with
precision beta i t
right so now going back to the
parametrization here right so if you see
if we divide through by beta i t
okay you can see how these two map up
so watching this diffusion process for a
unit of time is equivalent to observing
one realization of this signal
and if we were to further take these to
be integer valued
take the total cap to be sum n
right then we see how this corresponds
precisely to the code example so you
have n total tests you're deciding how
to allocate these tests across the
different testing centers the more tests
you allocate the more precise that
signal is going to be
okay so the agent is going to observe
the complete path of each of the k
diffusion processes
so your history at any moment in time
okay is something that looks like that
your information acquisition strategy is
going to be a map
from this history
into a decision of how you want to
allocate your attention today okay so a
new choice of this beta 1 through beta k
vector
the the agent is also going to choose a
stopping rule so at any history you're
going to decide well do i want to keep
on learning or do i want to just stop
right now and make my decision okay so
the covent case that might be a decision
of whether to instigate a lockdown
at this endogenously chosen end time
right you're taking an action a from
some set cap a and you're going to
receive a payoff which depends on the
action that you take
on the unit dimensional payoff relevant
state omega
and on the time of stopping tau
and here we're going to be very general
okay so we're essentially going to allow
for any payoff function we have a mild
condition which says that holding fixed
your belief at the time of stopping you
prefer stopping earlier rather than
later this is going to accommodate most
notions of
waiting costs um but otherwise right i
mean this can accommodate so it could be
that you're trying to predict omega is
your prediction and this is some sort of
negative of the loss
it could be they are choosing between
different goods and their payoffs depend
on this omega and so there's going to be
many different kinds of decision
problems that we can accommodate
right any questions about the model
okay so if not a few more comments on it
okay so first it's not a multi-armed
bandit problem okay although it might
look like one at first glance
so the key difference is that we don't
have this exploration exploitation
trade-off in our model right so when you
make a decision of how to learn that's
just influencing how you learn okay
there's no flow payoff that you're
receiving as a consequence of how you
allocate attention
so there is a literature called best arm
identification which our model is much
closer to so the case of k is equal to
two does actually correspond to one
version of this best arm identification
model
um so there's something called the
knowledge gradient policy which is
essentially a myopic policy and that's
been shown to be optimal for two arms
with independent payoffs
so we're going beyond this in a specific
direction where we're allowing for
multiple correlated unknowns uh which
however are assumed to aggregate into a
one-dimensional payoff relevant state
so in the economics literature there's
been a recent literature on dynamic
learning from a fixed set of signals
this is just a sample of some of the
recent papers okay so relevant relative
to these papers we're allowing for many
signals with flexible correlation okay
dynamic learning models with correlation
are sort of notoriously intractable and
there's an important exception so this
line of papers
which looks at
this which considers the signal
realizations to be the realizations of a
brownian motion okay so relative to this
model we're going to have a finite
number of attributes and noisy
observations of those attributes
all right so let me jump now into the
characterization so i'm going to first
characterize this model for the case of
k is equal to two
uh characterize the solution um we're
going to have a slightly stronger result
in this case and it's also just going to
be easier to talk through
okay all of the main
insights that we'll find here are going
to carry over to the general result for
an arbitrary finite number of attributes
okay so let's start with k is equal to
two let me remind you of the model
so we have two unknown attributes theta
one and theta two which are jointly
normal
the payoff relevant state is some
combination of these two where again
remember alpha one and alpha two are
known
uh we're further going to suppose that
these are both positive so that's
actually without loss of generality
because if it were negative we could
take that attribute redefine it at uh as
its its own negative right
and then uh this would again become
positive
all right so let's define code i
to be the covariance
of
attribute theta i with the payoff
relevant states omega
and just to remind you that's going to
be this expression here
and so our characterization is not
always going to hold it's going to hold
on a condition on the prior belief which
is the one that i have stated here
all right so the condition we need is
that the sum of the two covariances
is weakly positive
right so what does that mean so this is
the expression written out
okay well sigma 1 1 and sigma 2 2 are
both variances so they have to be
positive and by convention we've set all
the alphas to be positive
so the only way this expression could
possibly be negative is if this
covariance
were quite negative right relative to
the sizes of the variances so
essentially we're ruling out strongly
negatively correlated attributes
right if that's not interpretable enough
for you let me give you three sufficient
conditions okay so one sufficient
condition is for the weights to be the
same so if you're trying to learn about
some scaling of the sum of the
attributes okay because the covariance
matrix is positive semi-definite this is
going to be
satisfied
another sufficient condition is just to
assume away negative covariances right
if they're both positive if it's yeah if
they're positively correlated naturally
this is going to be satisfied a final
easy sufficient condition is if your
initial uncertainty about the two states
is the same
okay so then under your favorite of
these conditions we're going to be able
to characterize the optimal information
acquisition strategy
okay so without loss let's let's uh
let's suppose that the first attribute
is initially weekly more correlated with
the payoff relevant state omega
okay define a t1 as on the slide
then the optimal attention allocation
strategy has two stages
so initially at all times preceding this
t1
the decision maker is going to be
allocating all attention towards
learning exclusively about the first
attribute okay again remembering that
the first attribute is distinguished by
having the weekly higher initial
covariance under the prior belief
after this switch point
the decision maker is going to allocate
attention in a constant mixture
which is proportional to the payoff
weights alpha 1 and alpha 2 uh defining
the payoff relevant state omega right
that sort of makes sense if an attribute
plays a bigger role in the payoff
relevant stage we should spend more time
learning about it
but i think actually what's most
interesting about this slide is what's
not on it
all right so one thing you don't see
anywhere in the solution is the
realizations of the diffusion processes
so what that's telling you is that
actually you already know the optimal
attention allocation strategy at time t
is equal to zero
we don't use this word adaptive very
often but since used in the theme right
this is basically saying that although
you are allowed to adaptively learn you
actually don't need to
um
right another thing we don't see on this
um slide is the pale function u
right so what that's telling you is that
actually the solution is robust across
decision problems doesn't matter if
you're trying to predict omega if you're
using it in a choice problem in all
cases you want to be acquiring
information in this way
similarly we also don't see the agent's
time preferences or waiting costs none
of that is playing a role and those are
all going to be features that carry over
to the general solution
uh let's just get a better sense of the
solution by seeing it demonstrated on a
couple of simple examples okay the
simplest possible example is that of
independent attributes
and let's suppose further that what
you're trying to learn is the sum of the
attributes
then what the solution says is that
initially you should begin by putting
all your attention towards learning
theta one okay that makes sense because
you have the higher uncertainty about
theta one under this prior belief
at some time specifically five six
your posterior covariance matrix becomes
the identity matrix your uncertainty
about the two attributes have equalized
and from that point on you should split
your attention equally between the two
sources equally because the payoff
relevant weights here the two alphas are
identical
yeah proof that you basically
uh experiment one of them until the
posterior covariance of the two are
equal and then you just proportions also
right so so almost um so here it's it's
equal because these two weights are the
same in general you'd have to take those
weights into account but sort of
the marginal importance of the two has
to be exactly if everything was super
symmetric then you could just start with
the alphabet
after two
fractions from the beginning until the
end was zero
and that's in fact the solution is going
to look like
although so let me just add right so
your intuition is very myopic and in
fact the solution is myopic but that's
actually something we're going to have
to show why this actually ends up being
optimal for a decision maker that
doesn't have to be acquiring information
okay so let's make an example a little
bit more complicated let's add in some
correlation
keep the payoff relevant state to be the
sum of the two attributes
okay then the solution looks largely the
same you still begin by learning about
theta one
there's still a time point by going back
to this intuition where the
uncertainty during certainty about the
two attributes has equalized
again after that point you're going to
split your retention equally
okay so what's changed is that this
switch point
is now later than in the first example
and also your uncertainty at the point
of switching
is going to be lower
and the reason why that's the case is
because this correlation that we've
introduced uh is is creating a sort of
learning spillover effect where in phase
one even though i'm only trying to learn
about theta one because the two
attributes are correlated that's also
giving me information about theta two
right so both variances are going down
meaning it's going to take longer for my
uncertainty about theta one to catch up
with my uncertainty about theta two
all right so let me now show you how
this generalizes to more attributes so
we're again going to need a condition on
the prior belief and in the paper we
offer three different sufficient
conditions you only need one for the
results
okay so the first condition um is
something we call perpetual substitutes
and this says that the inverse
covariance matrix has negative off
diagonal entries yeah
sorry before moving down to the second
taker
what is the when you say this method is
optimal optimal
what what what is the payoff you use you
define this new function
yeah yeah what
like in terms of squared error or what
are you trying to estimate okay good so
let's go back to model
uh so when i say optimally dynamically
optimal for the decision maker right who
has this problem where you can choose a
stopping time and at that stopping time
you choose an action and you'll receive
an arbitrary payoff according to some
utility function you
right so this is going to include the
case you had in mind where you're trying
to predict omega and your utility
function is something like negative of
squared error but that's just one very
special case right
so i could change your loss function
that would still be included it doesn't
even have to be a prediction problem it
would also be
included
right okay
and uh
you recently know the prior exactly
yes yes i mean so this is kind of funny
right because in a sense in a bayesian
model it almost like to assume you know
the prior you just you have the prior
that's that's a part of you but but i
completely understand that in yeah in
some practical applications there's a
question of what that prior is or means
um
yes okay you're asking about
why we need this
um
yeah so okay so unfortunately we don't
have a great intuition for the rule of
this we do have a counter example in the
paper um that you can look at where this
assumption fails and our solution no
longer ends up being optimal
let me maybe put off that until i go
through the proof so it will tell you
about how the proof works and i think we
can think about that a little bit more
there yeah the question just before so
here you are very general about utility
function so it's kind of a blackwell
approach to some extent absolutely yeah
yeah great yeah so when i get to why
this result is
right okay so this first condition right
we want the inverse covariance matrix to
have negative off diagonal entries uh
what that means is that the partial
correlation between any pair of
attributes controlling for the other
attributes
is positive don't get confused about the
sine flip that's just the way that works
okay uh amusingly
on the other end oh so also by the way
the reason we call that perpetual
substitutes is because that ends up
characterizing when it is the case
that all attributes are substitutes in
the sense that observing more about one
reduces the marginal value of learning
more about the others
okay so at the other extreme we have an
assumption called perpetual complements
which says that the covariance the prior
covariance matrix has negative off
diagonal entries
right so they're negatively correlated
in the prior
but
positively correlated with the payoff
relevant state which remember is a
positive linear combination of these
attributes so in a sense this is saying
they're negatively correlated but not
too negatively correlated and again in
the paper we show that this
characterizes the case when attributes
are complements in the sense that
observing more about one actually
increases the marginal value of learning
more about others
and the final condition is the technical
condition diagonal dominance
um so just a reminder
this definition here this essentially
says that
the prior covariance matrix is not too
far from the identity
so it's diagonal dominance of the
inverse covariance matrix so we want the
diagonal entries to be large relative to
the sizes of the off diagonals
okay so then under any of these
conditions we're going to get a
characterization much like the one i
showed you for two attributes
so there's going to be a sequence of
time points
and a sequence of nested sets
such that an optimal information
acquisition strategy is described by a
deterministic path of attention
allocations
where at each stage
the optimal attention allocation is
constant so there's some constant
mixture
over the sources in the corresponding
set
right so you start by learning about
some sources
okay going back to rod's intuition right
these are going to be sources with the
same highest marginal value of learning
at some point in time so those sources
are going to decrease in value at some
point in time uh their value equals that
of some source outside of your initial
set okay so you expand your set move to
a new mixture okay learn constantly with
that mixture so on and so forth at the
very end again you're going to be
acquiring information in a way
proportional to your weight vector alpha
okay and then again uh let's observe
right this has the same qualitative
properties of the solution i showed you
earlier so first this solution is
history independent you can map out the
full path of attention allocations from
time zero and the only things the only
primitives that matter are the weight
vector alpha defining omega
and your prior covariance matrix sigma
all right also this is again independent
of the stopping rule and we feel like
that's actually very useful for
applications in the sense that you don't
actually have to solve for the the
information acquisition strategy and the
stopping rule jointly right what you can
actually do given our results is you can
take information acquisition almost as
exogenously given right just suppose
that information comes in this way
and then you can solve for the stopping
rule in that model
and again the payoff function doesn't
appear so what we know is that the
solution is robust across decision
problems
exclusive expression for these ti's
we do yeah yeah so um so it's in an
appendix
i mean okay there's a question
by explicit uh
there's an algorithm that you can use to
compute this entire so all the time
steps t and these the sets be
using alpha in sigma
it could be
yeah right so i mean that's why this
result was surprising for us because in
a sense that was also our intuition
right that somehow depending on what
you've learned that might want to uh you
might want to change how you
subsequently allocate your attention
um so right so none of this is
restricted to be history independent it
just turns out that we're often optimal
solution is to actually decide that all
these sets
even though we are absolutely here
so back to the k important case does t
bond depend on the charge
no nothing in the solution right so none
of the time steps none of the sets no
not the mixtures everything you know um
everything is independent
like
you may want to equalize the value of
the information you get from exploring
the two options and that kind of
information should be found that you
should be functioning
and what's the intuition that you know
okay so so let me now get into an
explanation of the results right so why
is this all true why do we have these
properties
uh so i think it's useful to begin by
thinking about
actually the static version of our
problem right so again suppose where we
have these three different testing
centers in the static problem you just
have a one-time budget
let's say of t-total tests that you're
going to allocate across your different
centers
because we have gaussian signals
all information about omega can be black
or bright right based on the posterior
variant
of omega that is induced by acquiring
those signals
and moreover the posterior variance in
this gaussian world doesn't depend on
the signal realizations it just depends
on the counts right how many
tests you've allocated to each of these
testing centers so in the static world
we can already see of these these uh
these properties that i've
emphasized right what you're going to
want to do is you're going to want to
choose an allocation of your t-total
tests
in a way to minimize the posterior
variance about omega subject to your
budget constraint and you're going to
want to do that no matter what the
decision problem is
so for each t let me define q star of t
to be the optimal out of the optimal
static allocation of t total tests
right in this problem here okay so any
questions first about the static
version so now let's take a step towards
the dynamic problem uh let's first
consider an easy version of the dynamic
problem so suppose you're acquiring
information over time but you know when
you're going to stop right so at period
100 i'm definitely going to stop and
make my decision then okay well actually
that problem is a lot like the static
problem because if you know when you're
going to stop then all you're going to
care about is the posterior variance of
omega at that known time of stopping so
in fact the solution is the exact same
right whether we call t a fixed one-time
budget or t the end date at which you
stop you're still going to want to solve
this problem your solution is still
going to be to end up at this vector
q star and the order in which you
allocate your attention up until that
point of stopping isn't going to matter
right so everything still looks good in
that version of the problem okay now
let's go to our full dynamic problem uh
where you're possibly stopping at some
um
where okay where you have a distribution
over times at which you stop right so
what can go wrong then
okay well suppose i told you that the
optimal solution
if you knew you were going to stop at
time 100
were to allocate all of your tests to
testing center one
right so the t optimal vector for t is
equal to 100 is 100
but
suppose that
if you knew you were going to stop at
time 101
the optimal way to allocate your tests
would have been to allocate one test to
testing center one
fifty to two and fifty to three
now
these two allocations are in conflict
with one another
right if you've reached this at time 100
you certainly can't reach this at time
101 in particular it actually requires
you to take back tests that you've
already allocated to one testing center
so this kind of thing is creating an
intertemporal trade-off
right you have to decide as a decision
maker do i care more about reducing my
uncertainty about omega at time 100
or do i care more about reducing my
uncertainty at time 101
and for that problem you know all of
these things that we just said didn't
matter are going to matter right so the
payoff function your time costs all of
those things are going to play a role in
how you emphasize these different
periods
okay so that's a problem
so let's just assume that problem away
right suppose it were the case that
actually q star of t so these t optimal
attention allocations
for the static problems with a budget of
t suppose that those vectors were
actually monotone monotone increasing in
each of their coordinates
what that would mean is that it would
actually be possible to string together
all of these t optimal solutions using a
single deterministic sampling strategy
and moreover so if such a strategy
exists let's call it uniformly optimal
moreover along that strategy what you
would be doing is minimizing posterior
variants about omega at every moment of
time
because remember that's how we defined
the t optimal
attention vectors
so intuitively it might sound like such
a strategy is great if it exists and
it's what you should use for any
decision problem um it's actually a
little bit more subtle than not okay so
that actually does require proof uh but
it is true that if this strategy exists
that's going to be best in a blackwell
sense okay uh for any intertemporal
decision problem that you might face
all right uh so
what our different sufficient conditions
are actually doing is ensuring that in
fact these t optimal attention vectors
are monotone
yeah great thank you because that's
that's very important
um so q street is a solution to this
problem
when your total budget is t
so i can ask
right so i think you know for us it's
easiest to think about t as like
time right so you said something but it
should increase in
your last slide right that's right
that's right so as i increase t
it should be the case
that the optimal amount of each of these
sources you require
is also increasing right it shouldn't be
that it gives you more uh a bigger
budget and suddenly you're like i
actually wish i had i wish i could take
away attention to
okay so actually going to your question
right so uh sufficient conditions ensure
that this is in fact increasing in t
so when would that be the case
all right so for the economist in the
room this has a relationship to a
classic
consumer demand problem
so suppose you have a utility function
which is defined over a consumption of
good of k different goods
all right so let's let dp of w
denote the consumer's demand function
subject to the budget constraint
where p is the price factor q is the
quantity of each good that you've
acquired and w is your total wealth
so you might recall that we say that
demand is normal
if each coordinate of this demand
function is increasing with your total
income w
right so as you get richer you're going
to demand more of each of these goods
so in our problem
let's let your utility function be the
negative of the posterior variance
function let's let the price vector be
the vector of all ones
and your wealth is your attention budget
t
then normality of demand is precisely
the same as monotonicity of these t
optimal attention vectors right it says
that if you get more attention to
allocate you want to acquire more
information from each of the sources
so one of our sufficient conditions
perpetual complementarity is actually
directly related to a sufficient
condition for normality of demand in
this literature
um the other two um
we don't know of analogs uh we're
exploiting properties of this specific
utility function to derive them but we
also haven't thought so far about
whether they might actually be
interesting outside of this specific
utility function as well so that's
actually an open question
all right so then when you have
existence of this t optimal attention
vector um which is increasing in t
then
the attention allocations beta t are
simply going to be the time derivatives
of these t optimal attention vectors
uh which tells us that actually what
you're doing right so we've already had
a conversation about this but what
you're doing is greedy optimization
right at every moment in time you're
just asking what is the optimal mixture
right now to maximally reduce my
uncertainty about omega and that's
actually dynamically optimal
so so right so we've talked to this
intuition a bit already but so at each
stage you're going to be optimally
dividing your attention across those
attributes with the highest marginal
value for learning about omega
at each stage okay so this is a first
order calculation depend on the mixture
itself over those sources we need to
consider a second order effect and the
specific mixture that you're going to
choose is one that's going to maintain
equivalence of the marginal values of
the sources in that set okay so they're
going to decrease together
and then at some point in time some
other attribute outside of your set is
going to have the same marginal value at
that moment you add it into your
observation set so on and so forth
any questions about
this proof outline
and also how am i doing on time
this generalizes to any
function you
immediately i mean that this something
like sorry by function you do you mean
the utility function or do you have them
in a different part of the problem
yeah so so right um
this limit here is what tells us that
the utility function doesn't matter
so do you believe me that in the static
case the utility function doesn't matter
i believe okay all right so yes i mean
this is actually kind of cool so this is
one thing that's special about gastric
which is that you can actually block all
over you can have a big order over
signals about a more dimensional
national state
um
so you know it doesn't matter what
you're trying to use the information for
um right so it doesn't matter what
utility function you have as long as
it's just defined on a mega interaction
you're going to just want to minimize
your uncertainty about about omega so
that's known in the static case and
it should be monotone
so in the static case this is well known
in the dynamic case this is less well
known there's a paper by green shape
which essentially says that if you can
minimize posterior guardians at every
moment of time that's also blackwell
best and we extend that result to
considering um allowing for you to
condition your actions on the history so
we go generalize it a bit but
essentially everything
so it doesn't even matter how you
depends on on top
or right yeah so so right good so you
know we are imposing like there are
definitely restrictions in this model
right like the union dimensional
parallel state is is an important
restriction but what you can get in
return for that is just complete freedom
of utility function complete freedom
with time costs right so how it depends
on
complete freedom and right what like if
you are thinking about prediction
problems completely different and what's
going on
sorry one more question about the
utility function um i just want to i
just want some clarification about the
action a in the utility function i don't
see how it is modeled or if it doesn't
get mentioned after its definition
uh so yeah again it doesn't really
matter right so the way the mobile is
set up is that whenever you stop there
is some action setting path you choose
some action from that set to maximize
your payoffs subject giving your belief
at the time of stopping
but because the result holds for any
utility function any choice of action
set that's why i'm not playing you know
i'm not mentioning it yeah
so i'm not familiar with this blackwell
literature but it feels like if you is
just one dimensional in omega then you
can't do much better because the action
step is completely looking great it's
like i learned omega i have some other
set of actions i have this utility
function that's a function of omega in
action so then i just need to take some
action once i've learned our name
and so the best
to do is learn
omega is that the right intuition for
what's what's going on like it feels
like the fact that you use
one-dimensional
erlang but the fact that omega is a
scalar feels important to this is that
is that the correct intuition or not
i wouldn't say it's a wrong intuition
but it's maybe a bit misleading in the
sense that uh that intuition would apply
for
signals that have arbitrary
distributions
right as long as it may as long as the
media is conventional and this entire
argument relies heavily on the
assumption of gaussian sure sure but i'm
taking omega like i can compute the
variance and omega and i have i've
learned closely and sure but
right but in general variance would not
be a submission statistic for for this
decision
right
now
thank you
okay so great um so we find this the
solution interesting to sort of these
conceptual properties for this history
independence and the things we've been
discussing together but in addition
because the solution is so tractable um
we think that it's useful for
for problems where maybe the information
acquisition strategy isn't actually your
end goal right it's actually an
intermediate step in learning about
something else
uh and that's something that we exploit
ourselves in the paper so let me just
briefly so actually how am i doing my
time now so actually
you have now you have someone now i have
seven stars okay all right no worries um
so then yeah then i'll just tell you
just i'll have one slide on each of the
applications and then if it's something
that you're you find interesting um you
know it'd be great for be great if you
took a look at the paper i'd also be
very happy to uh to talk more about it
offline is that a question uh i think
the final stage is very pretty and easy
to explain to people like can you
quantify how super optimal it is to just
apply the the final stage policy since
the beginning as a function maybe of how
that you are
yeah that's an interesting question so
you're asking what happens if i just
um
if i just
right start with the final stage where
i'm i'm dividing my attention
yeah yeah
yeah so it's quite possible that would
actually be sort of approximately
optimal in some sense or that we can you
know we could bound the loss
um so that's not something we'll look at
at all in this paper uh but uh but that
wouldn't be shocking to me that were
true
right so just by the way right uh
we do focus on exact optimality here and
i think one of the values of that
actually is when we turn to things like
applications because when you actually
have the exact solution in closed form
it it doesn't make it easier to sort of
plug that into other models
uh so i'll give you a few examples here
okay so uh our first application is to
uh what's called a binary choice problem
so we have a decision maker who has a
choice between two goods
those goods have unknown payoffs v1 b2
and you can learn about those payoffs
before stopping at a time of your
choosing and then choosing between the
two goods
so there is many different versions of
this model with different distributional
assumptions on the payoffs there's a
recent paper by futenberg at all which
supposes that the payoffs are jointly
normal
so now observe that if we set our first
attribute to be the value of the first
good
the second attribute to be the negative
of the value of the second good
then all you care about
is theta one plus theta two which is the
difference between the two goods right
for your decision between the two goods
that's all you need to know
so we can summarize that as omega and
this is perfectly nested within our
month
also observe that
this
this specification involves equal payoff
weights which remember was one of our
sufficient conditions for our k is equal
to two results to hold so we don't need
any further assumptions on the prior
belief
right we know that for arbitrary sigma
our characterization is going to apply
and give us the optimal information
acquisition strategy
so we use this to generalize uh the main
result from this paper which is a result
uh regarding the relationship between
choice speed and accuracy right so if
you look at a big data set of when
people choose a stop and then their
decisions when they stop we can look at
the correlation so if you choose to stop
earlier does that mean that you're more
likely to choose the better of the two
goods okay so they have results like
that and we use this to uh
they have a result like that for the
case of an independent prior matrix and
we use our result here to generalize to
arbitrary priors
okay so this application is in a sense
the closest to our model
we're going to take small steps further
and farther away so the second
application is to attention manipulation
so in our model we've assumed that you
have complete control over how you
allocate your attention but what happens
if somebody comes in and sort of diverts
your attention momentarily towards a
source that is not in fact optimal for
you
okay so this is the question that
gossner would all look at
um so they study the dynamic
implications of a one-time manipulation
of attention
and uh they consider this in a model
where choosing again between goods with
independent payoffs
and what they show is that diverting
attention towards a specific good
is going to lead to persistently higher
cumulative attention paid to that good
and persistently lower cumulative
attention paid to all other goods so
they view this as one justification for
advertising
you divert attention towards a good that
leads to sort of persistent returns
okay so for various reasons uh their
model and ours are not going to be
nested in one another uh but we can ask
a similar question within our model
where we do have correlation and we
derive a complementary result okay when
we allow for the goods to have
correlated payoffs so the first thing to
observe is that their qualitative
conclusion can in general fail when you
have correlation
but it turns out that this perpetual
substitutes condition that i showed you
earlier
under that condition
then it is true uh that diverting
attention towards a good leads to higher
attention towards that source
going forward and lower attention
towards the other sources
okay and then the third application is
quite different so um right so here
we're just generalizing a result here
we're sort of complementing
an existing result
uh and then for the third application we
derive a new result in a new model
so we wrote down a stylized game between
a liberal news source and a conservative
news source
these two new sources are reporting on a
common unknown
for example the fiscal cost of a
proposed policy
um but their reporting is biased in
opposite directions okay so you can
think about it they're both providing
normal signals but the means are one is
to the right of the truth and one is to
the left of the truth
they get to choose the size of the bias
so how far you want to go in the
direction
um of your bias
and also they choose the precision of
their reporting okay so this is going to
be the the noise term on their signals
all right so right in the news context
we're thinking about this as how
how biased you how partisan do you want
to be and then also how much time do you
want to spend on making sure your
articles are actually accurate
and then given their choices
readers are going to allocate their
attention across the two sources over
time optimally
okay this is the part where we can use
our characterization right because for
any choices made by the sources we know
the full time path of reader's attention
allocations
all right so we apply our result to
characterize equilibrium news provision
in this model
which is going to tell us the
extents of the biases and the choices of
the
the noise terms the precisions
and one thing that we find is that
higher intrinsic incentives for bias so
if you separately incentivize sources to
provide more biased information so
increasing this part okay well first
mechanically that's going to lead to
greater polarization in equilibrium
because you're pushing them farther
apart but separately it's also going to
lead them to have incentives to provide
less precise reporting
okay so incentivizing bias in the sense
of a mean shift uh results in less
informative news in these two different
senses both of polarization and also of
noisier signals
okay so that's all i wanted to say about
those applications so just to conclude
uh so information acquisition is a
classic problem within economics but uh
relatively few dynamic models are
simultaneously rich and practical um so
we've identified here a class of dynamic
information acquisition problems
where it turns out that the solution can
be explicitly characterized in closed
form okay so just to remind you the key
restrictions are gaussian uncertainty a
one-dimensional payoff relevant state
and this one is actually relatively weak
right so
we allow for correlation but it has to
satisfy certain assumptions for example
not being too strong
and if they're willing to accept these
restrictions then we can accommodate a
great deal of generality and other
aspects of the problem specifically the
utility function and the agent's time
preferences
um and yeah at least you know in our
exploration we feel like the
tractability of the solution uh opens
the door to interesting applications
okay so again thank you for your
questions
i think that just to
give
[Music]
set up
[Music]
so
if you
thank you the organizers and thank you
for coming in
today i'll be talking about
retrospective search this is how we coin
it although the
idea is kind of relatively simple
uh we want to talk about
searching for something and the goal is
to
find that something that is going to be
best for you
and then just
pick that one up what could be an idea
maybe we're trying to find the